[Applaudissements]
il ya du public qui nous attend il est
un champion qui nous attend du tour il
ya à l'islam ou non olala c'est le
champion du monde de lancer de la
babouche championne du monde ça se paie
quand tu y avoir une arène avec du
public
non me fait pas honte non mais je rigole
pas on sait pourtant réussir et latin
cas de femmes et les chéris bon lancer
de babouche faut avoir le pied de guerre
allez on y va ce n'est pas le but
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur mans possible
c'est ma le format lequel ringard
héroïque sur la gueule des arbitres
éliminée à
ah ouais c'est changer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quand même l'enfant du pays
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
la visite
[Applaudissements]
merci
les choux de la nature il dit on
s'arrête
ouf en possession big française mais
tunisie mais que tu as fait tes choix
soit rester dans le gynéco
[Applaudissements]
alors je te jure cegos beau c'est beau
gosse tes frais merci à tous merci les
jeunes bas
m me plaît de la babouche d'or et c'est
moctar thiam emploi
c'est bon
deux motards
nation
[Applaudissements]
les rues de manille
ras bord de cars est aisé de la deuxième
journée où je vous dis j'ai été obligé
de ma provision prof de stretching rsa
et on a envoyé isabelle